foreign
[Laughter]
oh my God is that terrible what does it
taste like
um vanilla vomit
yeah I'm bruising like I mean that's
really terrible
that is horrendous you take another step
just in case no it's it's so bad I can't
believe it tasted that bad imagine it
hung over hung over like it's like
medicine I if I was hungover I'd rather
like have a grilled pork chop out of an
ashtray
like that is just there's nothing I
think you're gonna drink it again I'm
amazed that this is actually a product
it's very popular too
yeah stop drinking it's so bad I can't
stop maybe that's why it's popular yes
because I can't get a taste on it I'm
like oh this is good or no it's like no
this this is rotten